well it's been 70 years since elizabeth
ii became queen she's the first british
monarch to celebrate a platinum jubilee
no public appearances are planned for
sunday's anniversary which the queen has
traditionally seen as a day of
reflection on her father's death martha
queen had a surprise ahead of time she
said she wanted prince charles's wife
camilla to take the title of queen
consort when he becomes king elizabeth's
message reflects a wider acceptance of
camilla's status as a royal i think i
might just put a knife again i think
that's a really good idea
a rare public appearance this weekend
but remaining ever committed to her
royal duties even at the age of 95.
while queen elizabeth celebrates the
70th anniversary of her reign it's also
a poignant moment
and that's because she became queen
after her ailing father king george vi
died on this day in 1952.
the tragic news reached princess
elizabeth and her husband while in kenya
and the new queen left immediately for
london
she mourned with the eyes of the world
on her
and again last year when her husband
prince philip died
the queen has worked tirelessly for
seven decades
forging a bond with the public in
britain and around the world
i think she's been absolutely amazing i
think she's overseen
incredible change in the country and in
the world and she's held it together
with dignity
courage
and her service i think the queen's
great yeah i think she's a great role
model
she's lived a long life which is amazing
so yeah i always look up to the queen
yeah
in a statement to mark her jubilee she's
announced she wants her daughter-in-law
to take the title of queen consort when
her son prince charles ascends the
throne
essentially she'll be known as queen
camilla
the monarchy is often seen to represent
tradition but the aging queen has been
able to adapt over the years
she has managed to provide this sense of
continuity and stability but at the same
time
remained relevant because of the way
that she seems to have understood that
the monarchy does need to adapt and to
change in order to thrive
and
over time over
so many years and such a period of
change she has really worked to build a
connection with the public
a legacy that queen elizabeth ii will
hope the rest of the royal family can
maintain
you